se vogliamo rivoluzionare il futuro
dobbiamo rivoluzionare la scuola quando
mi invitano ad un convegno spesso da
mamma e da insegnante mi chiedono ma che
tipo di scuola chiedono i genitori e io
dico che oggi le famiglie non chiedono
un tipo particolare di scuola che so io
il tempo pieno o il metodo stai liriano
quando pensiamo al bene dei nostri figli
e al futuro di una società
prima di tutto ci chiediamo come fare a
dare loro la migliore educazione
possibile e quando parliamo di successo
formativo intendiamo due cose ben
precise
la valorizzazione massima di ciascuno
date le sue aspirazioni attitudini e la
possibilità di rendere questo utile per
tutta la società
e i genitori poi chiedono come avere la
scuola migliore per i loro figli perché
si sentono responsabili e lo sono del
loro bene e quindi del tipo di
educazione da dare loro anche fuori
dalla famiglia e la libertà di
educazione è un valore fondamentale che
è riconosciuto la dichiarazione dei
diritti dell'uomo
e allora esiste un modello di scuola che
garantisce una scuola di qualita e
tutela il diritto di scelta dei genitori
sì questo modello c'è e come dimostrano
tantissimi studi ed esperienze a livello
internazionale e quello che realizza il
pluralismo educativo
cosa vuol dire vuol dire un sistema di
scuole decentrato
e flessibile in cui lo stato riconosce
finanzia e controlla tante scuole che
però sono autonome che possono quindi
fanno parte di un unico sistema ma
ognuna offrendo un proprio metodo e
stile educativo con una maggiore
soddisfazione di docenti ed i genitori
che possono scegliere la scuola più
adatta ai loro figli senza
discriminazioni per i meno ricchi e
questo che cosa porta
questo porta dinamismo a tutto il
sistema fa salire il livello di
efficienza e quindi di qualità e questo
tipo di modello e attuato in tantissimi
stati in svezia dal 92 è stato
introdotto il buono scuola che permette
alle famiglie di scegliere senza pagare
una retta con risultati nei livelli
delle competenze sopra la media della
organizzazione per la cooperazione e lo
sviluppo economico
il lussemburgo le spese per le scuole
sono tutte allo stato in francia è
possibile scegliere tra quattro tipi di
scuole alternative a quello che dallo
stato
in germania la possibilità per i privati
di istituire scuole è riconosciuta dalla
costituzione
in inghilterra nel 2020 dopo una ventina
di anni di sperimentazione tutte le
scuole inglesi saranno autonome e questo
sistema si contrappone a quello invece
di tipo standardizzato uniforme e
centralistico come quello che abbiamo in
italia
in italia la costituzione riconosce
la libertà di educazione ma le leggi
scolastiche purtroppo non la
garantiscono nei fatti perché è a tutti
gli effetti noi possiamo scegliere solo
un tipo di scuola quella che offre lo
stato e chi vuole scegliere tra le poche
scuole non statali cosiddette paritarie
è costretto a pagare una somma che per
tantissime inarrivabile e anche una
doppia spesa le imposte e la retta ma
scegliere il tipo di scuola non solo è
un diritto ma innalza tutta la qualità
del sistema
i dati dell'insuccesso scolastico in
italia ci dicono che abbiamo un sistema
inefficiente rispetto alle risorse
investite un sistema con il più alto
numero di abbandono scolastico
immaginate che ogni anno escono dalla
nostra scuola l'equivalente della
popolazione di bergamo o siracusa e non
si sa che fine fanno un sistema con 2
milioni e 200mila net giovani che non
studiano e non lavorano e il livello
d'istruzione fra i più bassi in europa è
un modello che anche regionalista perché
i risultati delle regioni del nord
italia rispetto a quelle del sud nei
maggiori test internazionali come l'ocse
il pisa sono drammatici i dati invalsi
ci dicono che il quindicenne
su tre al nord ha competenze
insufficienti in italiano ma questo
diventa il 50 per cento al sud
sempre per l'invalsi due ragazzi di 15
anni su tre al nord hanno competenze
insufficienze in inglese e matematica ma
questo diventa 50 per cento al sud e
anche in quest'anno abbiamo visto
cominciare l'anno con quasi duemila
dirigenti scolastici meno e circa 50mila
insegnanti di sostegno in meno un
servizio che ricade sulla pelle di chi
di famiglie di alunni ed i bambini
disabili e nonostante questo è un
sistema costosissimo 45 miliardi di euro
l'anno al 3,8 del pil
e se vi dicessi che il 90 per cento 95
per cento di questi fondi è tutto
investito solo per le spese per il
personale voi potreste chiedere e cosa
resta per l'innovazione e la ricerca e
gli investimenti
questo perché il monopolio
nell'istruzione led e l'efficienza della
scuola pubblica
la mancanza di competizione tra scuole
le rende come nicchie intoccabili in cui
si sviluppa di più l'irresponsabilità
l'inefficienza lo spreco e il mono il
modello del monopolio di stato
limita la libertà quella di educazione
dei genitori che non possono fare reali
scelte sul piano dell'indirizzo
culturale o o sul piano dei contenuti o
della qualità ma lei è anche la libertà
di insegnamento dei docenti quei docenti
che oggi spesso portano davvero sulle
loro spalle con tanto impegno
la scuola pubblica spesso con pochissime
risorse con poca formazione spesso
schiacciati in un sistema massificante
in cui
gli studiosi riconoscono anche come sta
aumentando il bar mouth è un sistema che
lede anche l'equità sociale tanti figli
di professionisti di dirigenti d'azienda
o di politici ma frequentano le scuole
non statali paritarie con la conseguenza
che queste nel nostro sentire siano se
siano percepire come elitarie o solo per
i più ricchi
ecco immaginate un sistema di scelta che
non penalizzi i più poveri che permetta
allo stato di dare a tutti non
un'educazione qualsiasi ma un'educazione
di qualità perché liberare un sistema
significa liberare energie qualsiasi
struttura che invece è troppo ingessata
porta al collasso e uccide cosa uccide
quella mobilità sociale che è
fondamentale per rimettere in piedi un
paese quella mobilità sociale che in
italia è tra le più basse al mondo per
cui i figli dei poveri
rimangono poveri i figli di ricchi
rimangono ricchi e possono accedere alle
professioni più qualificanti e meglio
distribuite che dobbiamo anche dire che
il monopolio di stato è un sistema
classista se è vero che l'insuccesso
scorer scolastico di case sulle fasce
più deboli che spesso sono relegate in
scuole scadenti di quartiere o in
percorsi scolastici meno qualificanti i
dati della rilevazione di almadiploma
del 2018 ci dicono ad esempio che sono
pochissimi i figli di famiglie poco
abbienti o poco istruite che accedono ai
licei o al liceo classico che è ancora
il cuore della classe dirigente
allora più il tempo passa più questo
modello peggiora la situazione e aumenta
anche il gap con gli altri stati e si
perché se da noi ancora aperto il
dibattito tra scuole private scuole
pubbliche
gli altri stati occidentali sviluppati
stanno raggiungendo dei sistemi
economici più performanti che permettono
risparmi reinvestibile l'istruzione
stessa bilanci sostenibili aumento dello
sviluppo sociale ed economico come è
tangibile molti stati del nord europa
ecco quindi il fattore economico è già
un fattore fondamentale per passare da
un sistema centralistico e monopolistico
dell'istruzione ad un sistema
pluralistico
ecco ma io penso che ciò che economico
sia anche umano e ciò che è umano che
migliora la vita in termini di qualità e
di valori e anche economico
se una scuola può accogliere l'infinita
moltitudine la varietà di umanità di
bisogni di provenienza sociale di
talento dei nostri giovani perché ecco
le scuole di scelta sono più efficaci
nel migliorare le potenzialità dei
nostri giovani sono più efficaci nel
diminuire lo svantaggio iniziale come
dimostrano gli studi tra le comunità
afroamericane in scuole indipendenti in
stati uniti sono scuole che creano
comunità educanti forti intorno a metodi
e valori condivisi
quelli che ispi cieli si chiamano
comunità funzionali sono scuole che
riescono a potenziare molte competenze
sia cognitive che sociali come
dimostrano tantissimi studi sia europei
che americani dagli anni 80 ad oggi e
promuovendo pluralismo educativo
noi difendiamo la ricchezza del
pluralismo culturale che ci sta tanto a
cuore allora la scuola come lo stato
deve rispondere alla richiesta di senso
dei nostri giovani alla loro richiesta
di speranza alla richiesta del diritto
di scelta dei genitori e all'urgenza di
rimettere in piedi un
paese dalle sue fondamenta e tutti noi
siamo chiamati responsabilmente ad
impegnarci per chiedere per difendere la
libertà di scelta educativa e pluralismo
come genitori o come i futuri genitori o
semplicemente come adulti a cui a tutti
noi è affidato il bene delle prossime
generazioni per dare ai nostri figli un
futuro e per uscire anche da da chiusure
ideologiche per per cogliere che ciò che
è pubblico non vuol dire che è statale
ma pubblico e ciò che è per il bene di
tutti
e allora ecco oggi occorre rimettere al
centro educazione ed arrivare ad una
riforma coraggiosa a ad un sistema di
scuole autonome e libere e serve oggi
chiederci se la qualità della formazione
è un bene per tutta la società
una democrazia senza di questo muore
e allora e impegnarci della libertà di
educazione è importante come impegnarsi
per l'ambiente e per lo sviluppo di
tutte le politiche verdi e allora
impegniamoci tutti e già si può
cominciare da un passo concreto
cominciamo a chiedere sempre di più di
partecipare alla scuola dei figli di
essere coinvolti in quelle che sono le
scelte educative di costruire una scuola
più bella insieme alla scuola stessa di
costruire una scuola sempre più ricca e
poi una scuola sempre più libera la
scuola libera libera l'umano la scuola
libera per te liberal inedito che c'è in
ciascuno di noi
in ciascuno di loro grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]